-Hey, this is --
Like, game shows are
one of the things
that are coming back,
and you've been participating in
some game shows.
Do you enjoy that?
Because I think
I would not enjoy that.
-Okay, so, yeah,
the game shows are, like,
one of the first things
to come back.
So, I really like playing
"100,000 Pyramid,"
you know,
when I'm called to do it,
when I'm called for that
service, to go play "Pyramid."
So, I just did that with
Ana Gasteyer
as the other celebrity.
And, yeah, that's --
So, that's fun.
And then I just did
another show for Quibi
where you guess if things
are cake or not.
And that was also with Ana
-So, now, how does it work
that you guess
if something's cake or not
-Okay, it's called "Eye Candy.
It's based on a Japanese show.
I'm not hosting
this or anything.
I was just a contestant,
whatever, a celebrity guest.
But then, like, you see --
-I'm not accusing you
of hosting a television show
-No, but, I mean,
I wish I was hosting.
I wish this was my gig,
because I want to, like,
do a lot of game shows now
'cause they're --
I just like the game.
So, then you decide
if something's cake or not
with your partner.
And then, like,
the way you tell if it's cak
is that they have you bite it.
So, like --
And these look so real.
So, sometimes, you bite into
like whatever, this metal thing,
and it's actually cake.
Other times, you're biting
and it's just metal,
and that's how you find out.
-It seems to me that you mus
have to sign a release
if they're letting you
bite into metal.
-I heard they have
a dentist on call.
But, no, my teeth were fine.
But this is my thing now.
Like, I'm at the point
in my career where
I think the pandemic and,
plus -- I don't know --
sheer laziness, I just want to
go play game shows.
-Is there an intruder coming
into your home?
You keep looking off
to the side.
I'm wondering if someone -
Is there a home invasion
taking place?
Because you've can -- If you
want to go deal with that...
-No, I think I'm just,
like, looking
for a fake audience
or something.
I'm looking for reinforcement.
It's like a Pavlov Dog thing
-Oh, man. Welcome to my life
Who's better at "Pyramid"?
You or Ana?
-Well, we're both pretty good.
-Alright.
I didn't -- I'm not trying t
drive a wedge here.
-Let's just say I made
several trips to the
winner's circle.
-Oh, really?
Do you -- Is there -- Do you
have a strategy for "Pyramid
or does it just come
naturally to you?
-No. Seth, you've just
got to go fast.
You've got to be quick.
You've got to go fast.
I hope I'm allowed to
say all of this
and not ruin the suspense
when you all watch "Pyramid.
-I mean, I think we know
how "Pyramid" works.
-No, but I mean whether
or not -- how it went.
-Oh, I see. Oh, I see.
-I don't want to ruin things
-Is it like "The Masked Singer"?
Do they know you're
Rachel Dratch the whole time
-Yeah, they know that I'm me
Yeah.
-Okay, that's good.
So at least that's not
a spoiler.
-Yeah, at least that's not
a spoiler, yeah.
-I was going to watch,
but now I feel like
I kind of know how it ends
-Well, you might not know.
Maybe I won one.
Maybe I lost another.
You don't know.
Wait, Seth.
Once, I was on your show,
and I talked about having these,
like, really big plans,
like, mom plans,
and then they
would always fail, like,
as opposed to when you just,
like, stumble upon a fun time.
The plan thing would fail.
So, over the summer,
I had this big plan to take El
to a drive-in movie,
because we were on Cape Cod.
And I was all excited about it
And I made the
plan and everything.
And we go there,
and it was "Jurassic Park.
And what you forget about
drive-in movies is that,
first of all, the car, like,
heats up really hot,
and -- but then,
if you open the windows,
like, all these mosquitos
come in.
So it's like a lose-lose.
And then we were watching
"Jurassic Park."
You might forget,
but, like, "Jurassic Park"
has kind of a really
slow beginning,
which I sort of forgot about
I mean, if you're a kid,
'cause it's all about, like,
build-up of the island
and everything.
And, so, about
like 45 minutes in,
he just turned and he's like
"I want to leave."
And I was just like, "Oh, no."
And I was like, I seem to report
those stories to you
where Eli wants to leave
shows and movies.
-I forgot that --
He must have been like,
"This is the most boring
movie about DNA."
-That's kind of what
it was like, yes.
And, like,
a mad scientist, yeah.
By the time the dinosaurs came
he was already checked out
a little bit and hot as heck
-Well, the best-laid plans
Hey, Dratch, it is always
the best to see you.
And I can't wait --
-I'm looking at the audience
to see how they thought it went.
Audience?
-And everybody here seems like
they were really into it.
I love you so much,
and I'll see you so soon.
-I hope so.
Good to see you, Seth.
-Good to see you, too.